welcome to philanthropy in action where
we engage philanthropist activists
students and the community in
discussions and how we use our time
talent and treasure to make the world a
better place I am Maxum thorne and I
teach philanthropy in action at Yale
today's guest is Beth Neville Evans a
descendant from a long line of
missionaries and the president of extra
tan foundation which is doing important
work in Guatemala Beth Neville thank you
so much for coming it is such a pleasure
to see you again for making the trip to
new haven fun over here thank you we
also have with us students from Yale
University well who asked to introduce
themselves starting with seson and I am
from Los Angeles and JE college Carl hi
I'm Carl said I'm also from NASA Los
Angeles and I'm a junior my name is
Matthias polities and I'm from Newark
Delaware my name is Christina we and I'm
from San Jose California my name is
Samantha Dinah from Denver Colorado my
name is Owen banks and I'm a sophomore
from Richland Washington right well
thank you again Beth Neville Beth tell
us a little bit about the missionary
history that runs through so many
generations in your family and also
where you actually spent your early
formative years of life I grew I was
born and grew up in Japan because my
parents were missionaries my father grew
up in China as a child of Presbyterian
missionaries and his father yes his
father also lived in China as a young
young child because his father was a
missionary to China so I would have my
cousins who are missionaries I have some
cousins and missionaries our 4th 4th
generation missionaries Presbyterian
mission and so this is dating back to
the 1800s at least yeah I shouldn't have
a date but I don't was probably the mid
1800s and do you think that that is part
of the reason why you do some of the
good work that you have been doing for
so many years well I don't like it when
people call me a missionary because my
work is not faith-based and I think it's
slightly arrogant for someone to claim
that they're doing God's work and
actually my father thinks the same thing
he sort of has he was in Japan for 20
years and recently said to me what were
we doing there telling people how to
live what to believe and he's sort of he
spent the last 20 years of his life
working with ecumenical relations which
is working with other churches or other
faiths so I i think that i don't i don't
have the the church is not in my work in
that way at all but I I don't even I
don't know if these kinds of values or
sensibilities are bred into one but i
guess the older I get the harder it is
for me to deny that that had something
to do it with what I do now yes now
before we talk about this passion you
had a previous passion that was quite
creative tell us a little bit about that
very jealous maxim's Taylor because
that's what I used to do I used to be a
Taylor yeah and I've made clothes for
tell us who for Tom Wolfe the writer
who's you know my most famously bespoke
customer and who else and Julian Bond
and Dave Matthews a few things after
Dave Matthews Band yeah that but for
summary I don't know why that happened
Tom Wolfe's sister was married to my
husband's aunt so he was kind of a
family connection that's what it but
mostly I made him bath robes and pajamas
I have made two jackets there's a really
really nice nice shirt I recently you
had to alter it didn't you or happy as I
he sent me yet no no he sent me an old
smoking jacket that I made for him it
must have been 20 years ago and instead
of having a new one made I'm patching
this one taking the cuffs off and
reversing them so that they won't so
they won't see the hole but I have to
put little elbow patches on well honey
loves it so much that's what so great
about him he loves his clothes so from
being a dressmaker or would tailor
general to such high-profile people to
moving and doing this kind of work in
Guatemala how did that happen I think
these kinds of changes its it looks
really radical from the outside in some
ways but I think changes that happen
start somewhere inside of you and you're
here for many years probably five I was
the last five years I was a tailor I had
this stuff going on back this sort of
vague dissatisfaction with the work and
I there was nothing wrong with the work
the work was great and the people are
wonderful and they are some of my
biggest supporters now but I just needed
I just needed something that was I think
it's something that would connect me to
I think I just really wanted to be
around people that weren't rich because
that's who I saw we my husband as a
painter his customers are all wealthy my
customers are all wealthy and we sort of
but they were not wealthy but we've sort
of walked in that part of society and it
just wasn't enough somehow but I had
that going on behind me and so when the
opportunity came to do this I just
visited the town of somewhat damaged it
done which is where our work is I kind
of just fell in love with the town and
and that's what called me first I would
maybe I can find something they will
just bring me back here and that'll
that'll rule that'll make the parameters
of my work and then later when I heard
that they had never had a high school
that crystal crystallized sort of the
plan well that's let's bring our
students into the conversation
assassin hello miss Bethany my question
is the second foundation now provides
funding for the local Association things
pronounced in hat but the ultimate goal
of the foundation is that the
Association be self-sustainable by year
2021 that it had the capacity to roses
on funds and manages various projects
such as the high school seeds of
knowledge on its own I was hoping you
could please if you could I was hoping
you could explain to us this model of
sustainability quantitatively and also
how the foundation will properly
transfer its knowledge base to the
Association so that the work is left in
capable hands yeah it's a process and
the reason we have fell into the 20 year
plan and that was because when I started
the foundation I was 45 and I thought 20
more years I'll be 65 it's time to
retire so that was always my my plan 20
years but it Bennett became part of our
philosophy because I would see more and
more organizations in Guatemala of which
there are many many still being run
after 20 years by people from the states
and that just they wouldn't give or they
didn't plan for this transfer of power
and so you would still have white people
in Guatemala running the organization so
it be I didn't like that and this may be
partly to my my reaction to growing up
as a missionary because you you see a
little bit of the same kind of thing
where these missionaries go down there a
bit patronizing and they know better
than local people and it's just a real
bad they had a tendency we have heavy as
Westerners so I've always taught we've
been talking about this ever since the
beginning that in 2021 you will have to
have money blah blah blah and so that
but the first step was that we gave a
scholarship to young men who
was in the states from some meditation a
ton to go to go to college and he
studied management business management
when he came back to Guatemala he
started working for us and he has no I'm
not a manager I never was able to manage
anything but he came back and has sort
of built up the organization of the
Association so now they they really
aren't there all self menit money they
managed themselves in Elias the same
young man has now taken the job as the
director of the foundation said would he
call it branch in Guatemala so he's
raising money and he's actually made 75
thousand dollars last year so I'm thank
you can play better than I am and I'm
really really relieved because I want to
I don't raising money is not something
that I particularly enjoy doing so I
think I think we're on track for the
20-21 Carl so part of our class one of
our one of our tasks is to figure out
we've been given a sum of money and we
are been instructed to kind of figure
out how to distribute this money to
nonprofits and organizations that we
think are doing at work and I wanted to
ask you so part of it is trying to
choose right and I wanted to ask you how
you chose this community of Guatemala to
work with specifically because part of
what we're deciding right now is Sri go
sort of more internationally should we
focus on something local should we do
something that we are really passionate
about or should we try and maybe
maximize the good that we can do somehow
even if we can even quantify it you know
are good to begin with had to give a
really tough job in a white my job is
easier because the community chose me
and I mean we it was just serendipitous
it wasn't that I went out and did
research ok where am I going to go you
know I barely spoke Spanish when I
started so it wasn't bad it wasn't a
love of Latin America let them but I
do I tell the long story short okay in
two minutes oh god I was on the board of
day methods his sister worked for me for
you know he lived in Charlottesville now
he lives in Seattle but his sister
worked for me and when he got to be
famous he formed a foundation and they
asked me to be on the board was through
that that that I found out about a young
guy from some my parish that I've had a
huge growth on the side of his head and
i'll tell you the longer story later but
the it the first time i went to some
what there was to take him back to this
town and that's when I fell in love with
it and it really did just mean I'd had
these NASA nations in the in my soul or
the back of my head or something saying
find something else but when I got there
we thought he was going to die we did we
had tried to find treatment for him in
Costa Rica how old was he he was 34 yeah
34 and and they couldn't fix him in
Costa Rica later he came to New York and
lived with my husband and me for 10
months and we would go up to New York I
mean we live in Virginia so he'd go to
New York and had these treatments and
David Matthews paid for all of it Thomas
was that 369 thousand dollars Wow a lot
of money and he paid it when I came back
from Costa Rica we talked and he said
I'm sorry that didn't work out and I
said well I brought back BMR I'm
angiogram so I'm going to try to find a
doctor here he said well if you find one
up I'll pay for it like that I didn't
even have to ask he said he's incredible
but it was a lot of money but when you
think about how it got where it took and
did you find a doctor found a doctor in
at Beth Israel in New York is a Mexican
man named alejandro Berenstein whose
parents had fled Poland as
young they had fun you know escaped Nazi
Nazi menace as children and met in
Mexico and he looked at me when I first
met him and he said I think I think I
can fix your friend but I may be the
only person in the world that can but he
did he thought it was strange and he did
to any did fix West Yemen the so
Sebastian's home now and he actually has
been engaged in the foundation that's a
husband how many years ago was that that
was 12 talk years ago and it was while
he was in my house and he that I found
out that there never been a high school
I had figured I would do some kind of
women's crafts but you know cuz that's
sort of what I do but he I don't know
what we were talking about any kind of
casually mentioned that they never had a
high school and I said really do you
think they would like one like that you
know and so he called down we had eight
phones and son Mateo ipython 88 there's
a town of 10,000 people and they're all
these community funds anyway he called
on two weeks later I got this official
petition so that's what happened it was
come up then I thought well I have to do
it I didn't know anything about
education I didn't know anything about
nonprofit work I really didn't know
anything except that i wanted but except
that this had been asked of me maybe
that's what it took to be asked I'm not
sure you know Julian Bond said when he
was in your seat that when I asked him
how did he become an activist and he
said because someone asked me I remember
that story it's incredible eyes at me
what me like that was his first reaction
and in a way that was my reaction too
because I it seemed overwhelming and I
didn't know about these things but the
more I thought about the more thought
try it
mario's hi I'm thank you so much for
coming I window Beth Neville has flown
in now a couple times in a month from
Guatemala right in the last month and so
we're we are thrilled oh yeah thanks for
coming in between yeah yeah just having
fun I'm really thrilled to be here yeah
I did want to ask is slightly shifting
gears a little bit about what when I was
look looking at the website I was
shocked to see that the illiteracy rates
in initiative san mateo i guess are
around seventy percent and that this is
much higher than the rest of guatemala
and i guess i was wondering and the
community came to you and asked about
building a high school what is the role
of activism in in this kind of situation
is it may be the role of the government
to provide a high school and i'm not
sure if the if you've thought about it
the community has already tried to put
pressure on the government to to do this
yeah i don't know how they would put as
they've put pressure and they've
actually gotten received they call it
receiving high school the last President
did start it just hasn't been the
governmental policy to build middle
schools or high schools anywhere and
they were very few of them now there i
think they said they've put them in
every municipality the last president
but that being said they suck they're
horrible the ones that the government
schools are just awful and i don't know
if that's because of the sort of culture
of oh its governing not a sort of
government work stereotype culture so we
we actually had it we started a middle
school and high school and there was an
offer from the government the Ministry
of Education saying will we're offering
a middle school so we hand it over our
school for years so that we wouldn't
have to pay salaries you know maybe they
would build a building and and it just
in one year just went tumbling down I
mean
and the quality and the assistant buddy
call it assistenza the the the rate at
which kids and teachers would show up to
class right what is that colony with
attendance attendance yeah thank you and
it just went way down how there's so
much so that the parents came to us and
said please PLEASE reinitiate your
school and we're willing to pay because
they have to pay it's not a public
school our school they pay that eight
ten twelve dollars a month but we also
try to keep it public in the sense that
we don't turn people away if they don't
have enough money we have scholarships
so I don't know it's a bad costs about
10 times that much to educate them but
active there's the community is very
active between a lot of things like
right now they're really against the
electric companies trying to put in a
big hydroelectric power station private
company and they're really really mean
they're actually taking up arms against
the engineers so it's kind of a lot of
activism there you know for lack of
activism didn't I think but I think it's
just hard going a little town going
against the whole big ministry of
education bureaucracy which is pretty
significant do you follow up baby well I
was just just curious um you know in
these various organizations I guess
through education maybe is that a way
that larger structural change can come
about that people are educated and then
themselves maybe go into government or
into policy it's our hope okay yeah
there's one little kid and I just saw my
way he's not I don't mean he's a little
he's just he just graduated last year
and he's going to study law and he's
interested in politics he's interested
in local politics and he'll he's such a
positive guy I think you'll be great so
yes that's a whole point is that they'll
do whatever it takes who knows what that
will be
Kristen hey thank you so much for
joining us today I wanted to follow up
on Mario's this question because I'm
also really interested in how education
can become a vehicle for creating more
long-term structural change I was
wondering if your foundation partners
with you know civil organizations with
the government to create opportunities
for students once they've completed the
education to create infrastructure
opportunities for them to continue using
and applying the knowledge they've
acquired during their time at the
schools like if if there is a model for
sustainable change in that water garden
paired up with local gut guatemalan
organizations right not actively more
we're more interested in finding outside
hell yeah actually the new mayor we have
formed a sort of good con vinny another
word i can't think of it in english like
a public-private partnership something
like this I thought there's a
partnership an agreement I think he
would call sorry because the new mayor
is I met in the States he worked in the
States for 10 10 years and he's young
and they had this whole energetic
wonderful team that really wants for the
first time I've ever seen Guatemalan
local Guatemalan governance where they
really seem to care about the future of
the town I mean it's such a stereotype
cliche to say that they're corrupt and
whatever but that's mostly what we've
seen is that the mayor's don't do much
really but but the new one is quite
impressively was just sworn in in
january fifteenth and so we do hope we
hope that we can actually help him with
our students use them to gather data for
instance on garbage water pollution and
and whatever we might do in terms of the
fighting the hydroelectric power company
and mining interests that want to come
in
to town but we have tried to I'm kind of
interested in getting the kids outside
of Guatemala as much as possible because
I think that that will give them those
much broader perspective and we have one
we have three kids studying medicine and
Cuba because there's not a single doctor
there's now one doctor that speaks their
language you know they don't speak
Spanish in the home they only speak
Spanish in school so he's he there in
Cuba and we have some in in Mexico
studying business administration than we
have an educator the guy studying
education in Guatemala City but I that I
think it still remains to be seen I
think an answer to your question we
would like to but there's these get the
schools only graduated five five classes
how pretty new so because it's pretty
new have you developed and that tricks
to gauge long-term impact or it are you
focused more on the short term for now I
just don't I don't think I know yet what
happened what you mean well the heart
what will happen how what will happen
with these kids you know cuz there when
they leave they want to they want it
they think that mean for me success is
when if they come back that's one one
way of measuring success they would come
back and find ways of generating money
within the town or they come back and
our doctor they care for their fellow or
they build or their engineers and they
build sustainable electric power
whatever but so far we can't know that
and I think what happens to is it the
the whole the whole migration flood of
migration to the States is new and
something that's only about 12 years old
they haven't been coming here very long
the economy in 12 years has completely
been taken over by remittances and that
and whatever the American economy
basically runs it so
we just don't know I mean they all leak
they come to the state thinking they're
going to build a house and go home but
it's too new a phenomenon and the school
is too new i think to make any
measurements yet that's what I think but
you are graduating students we're
graduating students we have a hundred
graduates and that's 100 more than ten
years ago I don't think there was a
single college graduate and maybe a less
than a dozen high school graduates
within this community of 50,000 people
that's changing but well I think it's
hard to know how to judge it I mean even
with all those good things there's that
has a downside I'm sure we haven't
thought of sessun thank you so much for
being with us today um I was just
wondering because you entered upon this
adventure with no experience and
nonprofits education I'm going to stop
for a second I'm gonna start over Sam hi
yes sorry pregnant pause hey Rick hey
Sam how I was just wondering because you
entered upon this adventure with no
experience in education nonprofit work I
was wondering what major challenges you
faced and was there ever a moment at
which you really questioned the
foundations of what you were doing and
what made you keep going wow I think the
hardest thing was probably the first
making the decision and I just did it
made that by talking to a lot of people
and having support one thing that I
haven't talked about as my husband who
has supported me off through all of it
and if he had been against it or hadn't
really supported me who knows what would
happen but there was a time in 2005 when
we had actually built the building and
it got stolen from us and by a rival
middle school came and took over the
hour day the day we inaugurated the
building they came up and took it over
this kind of drunken crowd and that was
kind of a big
appointment and I Avila I think the
lesson I learned was why do we have to
build a building first we only had a few
students we should have just put him in
a house somewhere that was a big lesson
and important but it was John I think
that kept me coming back that year
because it was a hard year as we went
that was just the beginning of problems
within the community sort of a fight
that I had to just remove myself from
making one at you know trying to urge
people to do stuff because I mean I my
instinct was they can't take our school
but they didn't want to they didn't see
it that well they have to live there too
they didn't they we gave up the school
he still don't have it we've built
another school but that was hard so did
you find that you face the strongest
opposition from the community or from
here in the States Oh from a community
within the community I mean it's just
that it's I have heard that in poor or
in the end in indigenous communities
that when one person or one small group
it seemed to be going ahead or getting
more opportunities or money or whatever
it is that the tendency is to try to
bring that that group or that person
down and I think that's all that was
just seen as well here's a big school
and we want it because resources are
scarce fighting they find out it's easy
to fall into that but i think the heart
the continuous line and always have to
write i always have to walk is is not to
tell people what to do the thing I can't
do that and I want to do it a lot of
times but I think growing up in Japan
help me with that because I see things
as an outsider my husband says I'm very
I'm most happy or comfortable when I'm
an outsider it's fascinating
Ellen yes I'm curious how your
experiences in san mateo have informed
your perspective on the education system
specifically in the u.s. so are there
any practices or innovations that have
worked for you that you think should or
feasibly could be applied in the US I
hope that I hope that there will be we
worse it was so hard for us to get the
school going and we had a local director
we still have a local director but we
were so focused on just going through
the hoops that the quality of education
at the school is really not so great and
we haven't learned anything yet but and
the last year we spent months rethinking
about reforming it and what we're trying
now and I think this would be we may
learn some things from this that could
be applicable to education here is that
we're doing project-based learning and
and the projects are to come from the
kit from the students and they should
have relevance to their life in some
imitation at them and so from the
obvious things seem to me like you know
deforesting how do how do we figure that
out what do we do about the garbage what
do we do about the polluted rivers blah
blah blah get and try and sustainable so
far they haven't come up with it because
we just started school just started
three weeks ago and so they're still
kind of learning this system but I hope
so I am NOT still I'm until this year
haven't really taught I taught this year
I have been teaching music and English
so I'm not an educator but I hope that
we what I think we will find is that
education should be local it should be
determined curriculum should be
determined according to the local
circumstances and I think there's a lot
of need for that here in the states when
especially like in an inner city or own
reservations or places where people are
marginalized or where they live in a in
a
polluted area you know you could find a
lot there's a lot that children can do
children student young adults what I
fits very exciting and what what these
children have that we don't well you
guys have it but but I see a lot of
teenagers in the states of the sort of
cynicism and about how the whole life is
so heavy and boring but they're just so
sparkly they're so sparkly and alive and
and if that's really great I love being
with the kids so you think there's a lot
of enrichment that can occur at the
intersection of sort of social activism
and education I hope so that's what
we're hoping here and one thing that I
would like to see is interchanges
between students here and students there
and so far that hasn't nothing's
happened but we have talked with several
schools here about that possibility well
thank you students Beth Neville thank
you so much thanks Melanie max on the
phone we all hope to be so sparkly this
has been philanthropy in action as Beth
Neville has passionately stated we all
have so much to give inside of us to
find that inner calling to make the
world a better place now what are you
going to do to change the world